hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep very excited to have
reality TV star clothing the maker wine
distributor Kristin Doty with us on this
episode of not too deep you know her
from Vanderpump rules maybe you know her
from her clothing line James May and
you're about to know a lot about her in
her new book in which she reveals all of
the salacious scandals tales and who
knows what the [ __ ] of her dating life
in her new book coming out in June get
ready for a very fun episode not too
deep with Kristin Doty the National
Outdoor Leadership School aka Knowles
empowers people to get outside where you
can find your purpose your leadership
style and go beyond your comfort zone
Knowles offers adventure expeditions
wilderness medicine clinics and basic
wilderness safety courses their
wilderness education experience can
transform lives and you can get 20% off
your next Noel's expedition if you go to
Noel's edu slash grace NOLs edu slash
grace offer expires February 29th 2020
terms and conditions apply find your
course today I'm so excited that you're
here I'm so excited that I'm here
yeah I have a billion questions when
we've had Stassi on before and I am the
self-proclaimed like Bravo
freak you guys just had Bravo con yeah
how was that for people that don't know
that's basically just a convention like
comic-con for Bravo fans yeah which I
can't believe it hasn't previously
existed
we did a Vander crawl a couple of years
ago in New York a van der cross yeah so
that was like you guys organized no is
Bravo so that was like the biggest thing
that we've ever done for our show or for
Bravo like as a cast and that was
essentially like a five bar like bar
crawl like bar hopping crawl and
interference all knew about it and they
were like waiting you know lines and
lines of people and that was like
complete insanity but yeah then there's
Bravo Khan and that's like van der crawl
on steroids
yeah yeah cuz it was in New York or hey
how was it overall it's it's over the
course of a weekend yeah it was over the
course of two days but we did a lot of
stuff but they also had a thing called
Bravo Bazaar where if you had like
products to sell so we had our riches of
WeHo wine they're like Tom and Ariana
had the fancy AF like book merch because
the book wasn't out yet and a lot of
other Bravo Liberty's had you know
different products they were selling so
that was really cool then we did a panel
we previewed the first episode for a
giant ballroom of fans and then sat on a
panel had to was that the first thing
that you guys saw the episode as well
we sawed a couple of days beforehand so
it could be prepared so you could
mentally prepare yourself are all
sitting on stage and all of our
wonderful awkwardness okay because
that's always my question and we just
had nene leakes on an episode and i was
asking about real housewives and she
says that she gets to see the episodes a
couple days in advance is that how it
works for you guys as well yeah just
like a few days ahead of time so you get
to have a couple days of a mental
breakdown you just Bank everything
you're like I'm ready to go I mean it's
I'm obsessed with the because it's so
bonkers to me because I exist online but
I try to keep my life pretty private and
I respect that you guys put everything
out there but it's not fully in your
control because you just are living your
life and then you just hope that like
all of the terrible things like maybe
like one thing won't make it but just be
prepared they're definitely going to Wow
that's so nuts yeah how do you how does
the season prep like how do you guys
start boarding do you guys have like
pre-production meetings do you have like
we have one right before we've done this
every season for eight seasons we meet
with our showrunner uh-huh and it's
essentially just to sit down of like
what's going on like tell me about your
life what's been happening City therapy
session with a showrunner pretty much
exactly you're like do I say everything
but if I leave something out and someone
else says it then it's gonna come out at
the end of the day everything will
always come out especially on matter
pump roles oh you might as well just
while you have the moment to do so Wow
okay talk me through the beginning of
you coming to LA you're working at Sur
and you're getting on this reality show
yeah I mean you're eight seasons in so
we're just surfer like I want to say
three or four years before Vanderpump
rules
okay so Housewives of Beverly Hills
started about a year before we did and
Lisa was like they she kind of pitched
this show idea because at the time it
was mostly because of Katie Stassi and I
dating Tom Tom and Jax and then there
was scheana and I was the original title
Tom and Jack - Tom's in a Jax and their
girlfriends are crazy
I think girlfriends and we had a staff
meeting one day which we had never had
before so it was like red flags all over
the place we're self linking out yeah
yeah we think we had maybe had like 20
employees there at the time it was
really tiny and and we were given a
number and this was everyone that works
there I think if you want you everyone
had to come to the meeting but it was
essentially a casting process so we sat
down within the roundtable with Lisa and
she was like who are you dating who are
you best friends with who do you hate
tell me the drama tell me all the gossip
what's going on when you're at work so
she played reality TV producer for all
of you guys in like a cattle call and
then you just had a choice if you wanted
to be a part of the pilot you could and
if you didn't you didn't have to and I
remember Tom Sanibel and I and our
budding indie acting careers thinking
like this is a terrible idea we're never
there gonna be a big movie stars like
we're never gonna win an Oscar if we
jump on this trashy reality show
whatever we are thinking in our heads of
like Jersey Shore and I'm TV or the
hills and that is really the only thing
that we had to gauge it off yeah because
we were not we weren't housewives right
and we didn't we weren't really familiar
with anything other than those kind of
you know young adults totally like
they're gonna manipulate us and they're
gonna tell our story in a terrible way
and really like we are doing our best
yeah and the first season was really
they were flies on the wall because they
don't know how to produce us or even you
know like a lot of people think like oh
well you're guided or you're asked this
well yeah of course now we know how to
it's a television show the other day and
we had
Kruse and we have call times because
they can't just follow us around 24/7
but at the beginning that's kind of what
they did well also because the other
major kind of vulnerable factor is the
restaurant like I don't know that I've
ever seen a reality show that takes
place in a restaurant like that before
you know I've seen scenes from realities
it shows in restaurants but one that
actually like rich people having dinner
yeah yeah like Lisa Vanderpump at one of
her restaurants engaging in a
conversation in which she is
disappointed in someone the but so that
must have been like a learning curve for
everyone involved yeah it definitely got
harder as years past to continue to work
at the restaurant oh right yeah I didn't
last very long but that's a testament to
your personality that a show that's
about a restaurant that you haven't
worked at for years are still a cast
member I mean has it because you guys
are all genuine real friends involved in
each other's lives before all of this
like eight seasons in how does your real
life compare to the TV version of it I
feel like now I mean this is our life
yeah it used to be like we're filming
for three months you take time off right
but now when we're filming and we're
airing 21 episodes Plus reunions yeah
that's months and months and months of
airing and months and months of filming
so there's very little time off yeah and
what they've been doing as of late like
in the last couple of years is when we
do have that time off if something is
going on they're gonna grab a producer
cam and they're gonna come and they're
doing special if someone's getting
married if someone's getting engaged for
example my book cover when we did the
photo shoot granted we don't know for a
fact if we're picked up for a season
nine we'd all like to hope so
yeah but just in case they brought a
producer cam to my book cover shoot
because this is a big moment we don't
want to miss this and like talk about it
later or do a pickup later it doesn't
make any sense well I'm glad you brought
up your book because that's always bring
up we need to talk about you have a book
that is available for pre-order right
now yeah comes out in June June 2nd um
by the time this podcast airs the book
cover I just saw it looks
absolutely stunning will be released
what's that well one I've 10,000
questions about the fact that you've
lived in so many you just lived your
life on TV and really put it all out
there whether you wanted to or not
relationship wise and so this book how
do you describe it for people this book
is by far the most vulnerable thing I've
ever done really even beyond Vanderpump
rules because of course it's it's a book
of all of my entire dating history from
like my first kiss to where I'm at right
now
which is single and figuring it out and
like on this self-love journey and and
who is the one do I know him do I not
know him yeah I don't know like I'm yeah
just trying to you know 36 years old
like just figuring you know okay that
I'm not married it's okay that I don't
have kids it's okay that I'm not like
all of my cast members or people from
back home sure but it's definitely the
most vulnerable because we talked about
so many things you don't see on
Vanderpump rules obviously mm-hmm but we
talk about all the things you have seen
on Vanderpump rules
but maybe the voice I didn't get to have
right that you're in control of the
narrative yeah that's very good well
blunt blunt and blunt and bluntly honest
and it's fish it's facetious it's very
comedic my writing partner is a comedic
genius when it comes to you know writing
books she's written many books yeah her
name is Michelle Alexander so she wrote
how to lose Guy in ten days that you
know maybe a couple people have heard
about at some point in their lives right
so it's it's half like your story and
half like dating advice at the same time
yeah it's all my stories they're all my
personal stories so Michelle's just
helping has helped me facilitate like
how to express those stories in a way
that's like fun for the reader that is
it kind of paints a picture for sure
like you could see this on it on a
television show or like in a few yeah so
but it's also very Universal because as
we were as I started telling Michelle
all these different stories she was like
dude you've lived eighteen [ __ ] life
this is crazy
and it's for the girls that are single
it's for the girls that are been married
in divorce it's the girls who are like
looking for the one or the ones that
have been cheated on or have been the
cheaters and I've done most of those
things there
all of them yeah exactly it's just
they're all universal truths that what
if you haven't been through it you know
someone who has yeah your girlfriend
your mom your sister whoever I think
it's really smart especially because you
know your storyline on reality TV
everyone has to take with a grain of
salt because it's presented for
salacious reasons is presented for
entertainment it's presented for people
they get upset for one way or another
about they don't have time to show a 3d
human being out of all of us exactly you
have to be one-dimensional there's
especially now we have a cast of like 75
million yeah exactly they're gonna take
the one crazy thing about you and then
like spin it as much as they can and so
it's I think it's really cool that you
get the opportunity to actually like
have some space in a book to put it all
out there today I'm just saying I'm not
crazy I'm just owning yeah crazy
I think everyone's crazy but we all have
like the context or the crazy is the
most important yeah he's got always our
fault I think when people are either
gonna go oh I get it now it all makes
sense now okay I just want everyone to
relate to it that's what I'm most
excited about it is there without
divulging too much a chapter or a story
that you're the most nervous about
revealing yeah I mean it's like I said
in the entire thing I mean it is there
are so many like comedic and facetious
and sarcastic aspects of it but it's not
just like a fluff book right there's a
lot of really deep moments there's
things I've never talked about publicly
in my entire life Wow like when my
sister is actually doing illustrations
for the book so I'm really excited about
that and so I said she's as she's been
doing this these illustrations were
giving her a list of them I'm like it'd
be so much easier if you just read like
the first version of our manuscript so I
sent it to her and there was one chapter
that she knew nothing about really
there's no but really no one does Wow so
there are definitely some really deep
moments that are you know a little
jarring or maybe a little heavier but
just very real and I think those things
are important because if I were leaving
one little piece out that I wouldn't be
being completely authentic and honest
with the reader yeah that's so cool
awesome very nervous and excited for you
that's so I mean I've written it there's
like there's nothing that's going to
like throw me off yeah
I'm prepared for the interviews I'm
prepared for the headlines I'm prepared
for the questions but like once I wrote
it and just really you know
authentically got it off of my chest I'm
ready to roll ya know that you're like
it's all out I think it's important yeah
it's almost like by being the most
vulnerable you're also creating a body
of armor for yourself you're like a
little prepared I've all my weapons and
I am the most vulnerable you've ever
seen I got to say it first so here it is
my version that's my real truth what
role do you get caught up in reading
gossip blogs and reading hell yeah yeah
really I mean oh God I commend anyone
who's on television that swears they've
never googled themselves if they don't
read their google or you definitely
don't believe you I don't take it as
harshly as I used to anymore because I
can handle the trolls now I'm more
defensive over people insulting my
friends then I am insulting me because
like you're sad life behind your laptop
you know in Middle America it's just
it's fine but I still read about it oh
of course I mean there's also be there's
a sense of curiosity and also like the
people that hate so hard care enough to
hate yeah hard so there's like a deeper
level of like yeah if you really didn't
care about me you couldn't have the
capacity to hate me this much exactly
and I mean I think the things that it's
having the trolls that bother me it's
the quote-unquote journalists and from
certain tabloids or like comms yeah that
don't want to really tell a story they
just kind of want to take what their
opinion is without fact behind it and
then write this like supposedly like
factual article sure that other people
on the Internet just random fans or
viewers will read this and think that
this is fact because it's coming from
right you know a journalist yeah so
supposedly and I've got a few of those
lately like someone someone wrote an
article saying I had tweeted out
someone's asked me about my ghostwriter
and I said I actually don't have a
ghostwriter I have a co-author mm-hmm
her name's on the cover
yeah she's 50/50 partners we've written
this entire book together and it was an
actual human
she's not anonymous and there was a
dot-com like sort of tabloid that said
someone should explain to Kristen Dodi
what a ghostwriter is because obviously
Michele has written this book for me and
I'm just taking the credit for it and
I'm like okay will someone tell your
want to be journalists or those writer
is because it goes right there someone's
anonymous it's things like that when
they affect like my businesses these I
work so hard for my book my clothing
line all of that stuff that's what gets
to me yeah but like call me crazy
because you saw something on TV I got it
yeah yeah I looked like I look like an
insane person
I own things that I am professional
about that's petty and that's you know
do your research exactly okay I want to
get into all of the businesses that you
have going on but we're gonna take a
break in a second I just want to know
did you have a person that you were most
excited to meet at Bravo con there are a
lot of people I mean I'm obsessed with
all Real Housewife self-playing in the
green room before the big watch what
happens live was one of the most surreal
moments of my life like I don't watch
all of the Housewives shows should I
know who everyone is and when you're
just standing in this like back ballroom
sort of area and you see every single
famous Bravo every you've ever looked at
before during and you know pros I'm just
like what the hell is going on and they
they knew who you are like you know
otherwise just yeah it was pretty
surreal have you had one and doing like
watch what happens live or any of that
like that you couldn't believe that you
sat down next to like if I met Ramona in
real life and I think I would lose my
goddamn mind I think it'd be like blink
for me in person
that's a bear and Bobby Moynihan and I
got to do all the whites of Vanessa
Bayer and I was like you know who I am
that's so fun okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I want to
talk about all these side business
businesses all these side hustles we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
the biggest risk in life is not taking
one and that's why Knowles the National
Outdoor Leadership School empowers
people to get outside where you can find
your purpose leadership style and go
beyond your comfort zone Knowles
believes in the wilderness and
experiential learning the outdoors is
the best classroom in the world founded
in 1965 Knowles is the leader in
wilderness education serving over three
hundred and fifty thousand students
since it opened Knowles offers adventure
expeditions wilderness medicine clinics
and basic wilderness safety courses
students can choose from sixteen
campuses around the world where they
embark on extended wilderness adventures
ranging from one week in duration up to
a full year instructors teach out their
skills from backpacking to sea kayaking
to rock climbing a mountaineering in the
world's most spectacular mountain ranges
Knowles is known for its proven
leadership curriculum that teaches
personal leadership styles teamwork and
decision-making that can be easily
applied to everyday life their
wilderness education experience can
transform lives to get started take
advantage of 20% off your next Noel's
expedition go to Knowles and OLS edu
slash grace that's Knowles edu slash
grace offer expires February 29th 2028
terms and conditions apply find your
course today would you buy a t-shirt for
$50 if you knew it only cost seven
dollars to make I would not and with
ever Lane you never overpay for quality
clothes ever Lane only makes premium
essentials using the finest materials
without traditional markups
they want you to know what you're paying
for and why so they tell you their real
costs and are radically transparent
about every step in their process from
the materials they use to the ethical
factories that work with no matter your
style or preference ever Lane's clothes
look better they cost less and they last
longer because ever Lane sells directly
to you their prices are 30 to 50 percent
lower than traditional retailers
essentials like their cotton crew
t-shirt are exactly
what they should be versatile simple
stylish and made from quality materials
and right now you can check out our
personalized collection over at everland
comm slash grace plus you'll get free
shipping on your first order that's ever
Lane comm slash grace ever Lane comm
slash grace alright let's talk about
James May let's talk about the wine this
must be bonkers to you that like
suddenly you have you're an
entrepreneurial 10,000 businesses as a
side hustle it's crazy but this is why I
did reality television I mean I can do
it for my health I couldn't afford
therapy so I got cast in a reality
television no it's for the platform it's
to do I did Vanderpump rules to like
have these businesses have these
opportunities have these platforms and
then to afford to be able to do things
for other people too so what's the
t-shirt company um James May that is
like my baby yeah how did this start I
started it I tried to start it years ago
mm-hmm I had no idea what I was doing
I but I just knew that that's what I
wanted I'm like it's what I wear it's my
uniform yeah and I thought I had a lot
of really great ideas I didn't know a
lot about graphic design or business for
that matter so it kind of took a little
bit of a plunge but it was the best
learning curve and I needed that to grow
and so then a few years later actually
last June was when we launched
relaunched James May my business partner
Megan and I she's been in the fashion
industry for like six seven years and
she knew that side of it I knew the
creative side of it I knew I had the
platform to do it and that's kind of how
we began and now we're going in a year
and a half later getting ready to go
into spring and summer and already
planning fall for next year and so cool
kind of trying to branch out as not just
someone from Vanderpump rules who has
this t-shirt line but as like a
standalone fashion brand well it's great
cuz it's not your name right so you've
created this whole brand that is
independent of you as Kristin on reality
television exactly it's super cool also
because no offense you seem like the
person that takes drugs and goes to
festivals
so this t-shirt line feels very inline
like hippie dippie like rocker boho chic
classic rock inspired
yeah just caring I love yeah it's like
an easy go-to shirt that's not what my
go-to is which is normally sweatpants
and like a stained t-shirt like its
purpose you can wear it with sweatpants
there you go there are t-shirts of
anything how is the learning curve been
on starting that kind of business I mean
it's it's been such a rad experience
because we're doing our own cut and sew
so essentially for listeners that don't
know that means like we have a
manufacturer in downtown LA okay we make
everything in LA for the most part we
have like one thing that we source out
but we're literally bringing them like
we kind of like this cut but we want to
change these parts to it this is the
fabric we want this is the wash we're
gonna do so we're doing everything
ourselves which is so like exhilarating
and like liberating and just you know
you feel so brainchild yeah absolutely
and we're you know creating all of these
designs by ourself for the most part
Megan my partner and I actually we have
a graphic designer who's a woman mm-hmm
a friend of ours who because she really
gets our vibe and I think it's important
to like kind of keep our team
female-driven cool and but for the most
part Megan and I are actually doing
these by ourselves like on Photoshop
that's awesome so it's just like yeah
I'm just so proud and we're we have a
few things in our collection we have a
sustainable collection so it's made from
plastic water bottles and like yarns or
work scraps from the bottom of our
manufacturing floor and then they create
yarn with that what-what way plastic
water bottles yeah shirt mm-hmm yes we
have a tank top like art we have tank
tops and we have a sweatshirt in the
tank tops are five plastic water bottles
each that's okay that's some witchcraft
that I'm down for it's really cool so we
like did a big beach cleanup last year
we've done a couple of those cool I want
a bottle that has James May water James
May water bottle because I'm saying it
no to plastic that's awesome as I'm just
like covered and plastic casings
speaking of which II let's talk about
basic which potion number one
this is Pinot Grigio on the planet
dammit okay so you and Katie and Stassi
started a started making wine yeah how
friend
okay myself and my best friend really
knocking point winery they're out of
Walla Walla Washington
they do a lot of I guess like celeb
collabs and things like that okay so
they came to us and just said we really
like your brand and you guys obviously
love wine and we think they can be
something really cool are you interested
and after we left our first meeting the
three of us literally went to like our
favorite bar in West Hollywood sat there
for like an hour and a half and designed
the label that like cool right there and
then like from scratch we were like this
is what it needs to look like this is
the font and it has to say this on the
back and like we need this aesthetic
from it to really scream that this is
like who we are and what we want it to
look like yeah and then they said what
kind of wine do you want we knew the
Pinot Grigio was number one thanks to
stassi's tagline and we just thought it
was the perfect like jumping off point
for witches of WeHo and then we do a
wine tasting and chose the wine and kind
of rolled from there that's so potion
number one sold out faster than any of
their celeb collab brands have liked
thus far Wow
so then we've rolled onto potion number
two the basic which rose a so that's
right is there a potion number three and
though I don't know okay maybe well
leave it to chance we'll see yeah you'll
see a lot of things on the season of
Anaheim pearls as far as oh I want to
know how the stress factory is on being
friends in real life
being friends on TV and being friends in
business like that must put a huge
strain on you guys yeah I will say when
it came to the wine it was the one thing
whether we were fighting or not that we
all always agreed on yeah that we never
fought about that's true friendship
agree otherwise like we always were all
on the same page about what kind it was
how we were gonna promote it what did it
look like yeah we were all excited about
it
but obviously when it's no it's no
shocker that you know we're not in the
same place that we were in before the
chosen I so that can take a toll you
know on that for me this wine is just as
important to me as James May is mm-hmm
so I put in the same amount of effort as
I do with my own company yeah even if
I'm doing it on my own yeah because I'm
really again this is something I'm so
proud of like we did this by ourselves
you guys like with this winery right
essentially this is our baby together
and yeah that's important and it's so
damn good
well there you go I mean the the proof
is in the pudding and here was in the
tannins but that's very cool that you're
able to kind of put emotional stuff to
the side and focus on this occasion this
is bidness are you do you get nervous
because everyone's in you're speaking of
business before our season starts like
how do you prep for I mean by the time
in this podcast airs I think the season
will have started yeah a couple weeks in
what's at this state at the end of
December filming recording this what how
do you prep to get started for a new
season of Vanderpump if there is any
[Laughter]
plan a couple vacation that's smart
that's smart for Carl if your phone up
there phone on airplane mode you know
yeah it's gonna say what do you cut
yourself off on tweeting live tweeting
as episodes go up I I try so hard to be
like okay episode one here we go watch
it come through let's do it like episode
four I'm like I can't [ __ ] do this
anyway maybe I'll tweet tomorrow like
I'm not even gonna watch it today I'll
just say we no longer do cast viewing
parties the same way we did season one
hey can understand season one we were
like pizza party at Sheena's huh hell
yeah everyone
and now we're like don't talk to me for
two months yeah like you were a soccer
team that was like we're getting pizza
after the game and now you're like we're
in college no everyone hates each other
exactly you were your good friend is in
comedy and you were in a sketch comedy
group are you still in that world I'm
not but we are doing I'm joining Rachel
Rachel O'Brien I'm joining her on a few
of her pop like a leg of a podcast to
her oh nice yeah so we're doing we have
like four dates right now through
between January and March very cool so
we're gonna it'll be like Rachel doing
stand-up for however long and then we're
doing a live podcast so I think that's
gonna be really fun very fun just
planning everything right now like what
games we're gonna play what are we gonna
do like how we gonna polish this because
it's all unfiltered I do want to ask
because you did say that you were single
what is dating life like is it just
because I don't want you dating your
work right now yeah I mean I don't have
time for anything other than the book
right now yeah that's that's actually
safe yeah they're trying to maintain
some sort of a friendship because we do
have our dogs together and okay I like I
would never you know they live with me I
would never take them away from him I
think it's important to try to maintain
as easily as we can based on whoever's
emotional that day oh my ex-boyfriend
watches my dog yeah when I go out of
town you know it's yeah he's trying to
keep this like modern normalcy divorce
also it must be nuts that everyone's
just in your business about that all the
time yeah of course but I mean I I you
know that's what I put my life out there
for I can't be mad at people are asking
questions about something that's going
on well they're about any more in the
business yeah that book sure no one is
safe I'm like Taylor Swift right you
know what is safe so my friend Mamie
wrote a book a couple years ago my
friend Hannah also and both of them had
to send chapters to me to like approve
of because they were like personal
stories that I was involved in did you
have to send chapters to I know
[Laughter]
to certain people in my past like
highschool boyfriends and things like
that that I still keep in touch with as
friends uh-huh
and I reached out I'm like do you
remember like this one night I'm just
like this that's the best way to start a
conversation do you remember this
whatnot and they do my my like I guess I
would call him like my high school
sweetheart I called him about a certain
night that happened I was like so I'm
writing this book there's this night I'm
gonna write about he's like I know
exactly what night it is I know he knew
like I've written this chapter in my
head for a year he knew what he did he
knew that I was kidding right about it
but it's like when it's that far back in
their past they're like almost excited
about it yeah I mean I if I were any of
these guys for my book I would not be
like bragging it's slight positive
confirmation that you also remember that
that happened also yeah what a weird
humblebrag to be like I'm you know John
Doe number two yeah they're [ __ ]
crazy to me a pat on the back okay we're
gonna take one more break and when we
get back we have a bunch of Twitter and
Instagram questions for you Kristen so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep it's 2020 and guess what all that
stuff in your home that you didn't use
in 2019 it's probably still there taking
up space being useful to absolutely no
one including yourself
so don't let another year go by just
sell it on Merc Ari
Macari is the selling app that makes
selling almost anything fast and easy
here's where you begin you just go
through your home you find all the stuff
you didn't use in 2019 the phone in the
drawer the jeans you wore that one time
that handbag that you didn't even know
was in the back Y it listing takes just
minutes you take a few pics you add a
description and boom your item is
connected to millions of buyers on the
app mercury will even email you a
shipping label when it sells everything
ships so there are no awkward meet ups
with strangers hooray
the app has over 500,000 reviews on the
App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try
ring in the new year with less stuff in
your home and more money in your pocket
with Macari that's M RCA our I mark re
the selling app okay Kristin before we
get into these Twitter questions and
Instagram questions I'm gonna ask you
the two questions that I ask every
single guest that is on the podcast and
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti act oh
I mean I'm just gonna be really
transparent Thank You mr. president
yeah that is a very common answer or
like maybe a couple of the guys in my
book yeah there you go okay the other
question that I ask every single guests
to tell us your worst pants shooting
story or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases or a
combination so mine for instance is
college jogging front lawn I can see you
are going through a Rolodex
squatting Runyon Canyon Oh runs in
Cannon
oh no I hope no one saw me I mean that's
the perfect place to do it
picture of health okay let's get into
these Twitter and Instagram questions
the first is what will you do after
Vanderpump from Nicki and that's I mean
you were saying that you guys don't even
know if you guys get picked up for
another season right okay just hope you
said it's weird purgatory that's why
it's important important it it's it's
important to be an entrepreneur yeah to
have other pots on the stove yeah what I
want this I know the book will do well
and we want the book to become a
television show oh cool that's our
that's our grand plan how do you not
have your own podcast right now that's a
question for grace Helbig
yeah I think I talk a little too fast I
can't understand you write it down Katie
wants to know to ask about Brittany's
Mimas beer cheese oh my god it is the
tits it is so good I tried I tried
recreating it for Brittany one time it
was actually I think it was on the shows
like a few years ago when we had her
like [ __ ] Jax party yeah
we got we got the recipe from her mama
and and she was like oh it's so good
it's not the same but it's so good
Jackson Brittany's wedding they had made
it in batches and we each had like a
little tub of it in our hotel or in our
castle room so oh right they're in a
castle and I just ate it with a spoon oh
we have one I mean it's on if I my
gastrointestinal system didn't explode
the thought of cheese I would love it
Beibei malla
wants to know what is the thing you're
most nervous or scared to see in the new
season of Vanderpump rules I mean it's
gotta be a little bit of fear of the
unknown
just like when I'm drunk and I fall a
lot it's just like a little embarrassing
trailer one of my girlfriends was like
oh my god who was that that fell and
like who do you think like I think I was
sober in that moment pretty sure we had
just gotten to the bar and I fell on my
ass but it just I am Who I am okay you
know baby drama and ice skating I could
not relate more to you I always say I'd
like a newborn deer trying to stand up
on ice all the time I have so many
bruises on my knees as a 34 year old
woman that it's like should be
embarrassed two peas in a pod right but
I don't play recreational sports I
shouldn't have these many birds but that
also must be do you guys get any say to
go to a producer you can't use that or
okay so I've heard of you or two they
would be like and that's in the trailer
yeah because I've heard the mythology of
like people that used to be on the real
world that they would like Pat their mic
to [ __ ] with the sounds so that what
they're talking about doesn't get used
or they'd like put middle fingers in
front of their face so that
like you already have systems for that
in the past I mean I don't do it anymore
because I mean you have to be
professional or like they'll just boot
you ever really well they they don't
care but yeah I have definitely gotten
in trouble in the past where I'm like I
don't like camera camera camera camera I
used to over and over I like action
production I do mics myself I have done
some really [ __ ] things in the past
my crew likes so [ __ ] disrespectful
like put my hand in front of the lens
I'm taking my life into my own hands
right real crazy Christmas moments and
they're like this is gold let her do it
let her touch the camera it's all good I
think they would just air it now that's
the difference I know I did say I feel
like all of those like what would be you
know taboo moments are just like the
perfect gold for them to use and they're
like break the fourth wall don't care we
don't miss that yeah the thing that you
could do that bother than the most is
just sit quietly if you absolutely
nothing just to indian-style on the
ground with my arms folded with a piece
of scotch tape over my mouth I just
start meditating and they're like this
is she's really she [ __ ] got us damn
it
someone's know what is the favorite your
favorite city that you've been to and
what was the best thing that you've
eaten there hmm so I've always said San
Francisco is my favorite okay
until I just spent a like five days in
Denver recently mmm and I fell in love
with Denver I've been to Denver before
but just kind of like passing through or
like a couple days mm-hmm and actually
getting to spend like five full days
there was it's just like my it's my jam
I was you know I'm cold all the time
forever and I might love it more than LA
the food and it was fine I don't know I
think as I'm a vegetarian right right
they were fairly vegetarian friendly but
like there's no place like home yeah
yeah the best it's LA your vegetarian
capital yeah for sure how long have you
been vegetarian since I was 11 so 25
years at 11 years old you went to your
parents and said yeah
no more animals yeah my grandparents oh
I'm from Michigan and my grandparents
were snowbirds I did like half the air
in Florida and half the air in Michigan
see I'm dating a guy from Florida and
I've only learned the term snowbirds in
the last six months mm-hmm so what they
do it's kind of like the New York Miami
thing yes but for like non model actors
and so we word I'll never forget it was
like in fifth or sixth grade and I found
out that dolphin meat could possibly be
in cans of tuna even though I never ate
tuna anyway and I was just like that's
it never again like they accidentally
like oh that's disgusting and I was so
angry and that I just never touched it
again so from 11 years old because of
dolphins yeah is this proven though is
this a real thing I don't think in the
day they said there could have been
dolphin mean to it because they set
these like tuna Nets up oh if they
caught something else than they did and
I just so cruel yeah that just grosses
me out I mean the closest I get to meet
at all is if my dogs are sick I'm like
my dogs are not vegan and anyways her
dogs are vegan or total [ __ ]
Psychopaths like I've had to boil
chicken for an upset stomach but I just
wear like the dishwashing gloves no
that's my friend memory does the same
thing she's vegetarians been vegan and
when her dog has an upset stomach she
literally makes her chicken and I'm like
all right yeah just go to guilt so like
the salad bar we already cooked thank
you
I don't know but that's Bunker since 11
years old Wow I just don't know any
differently ya know at this point it's
like you're not missing out especially
because there's so many advancements in
like the plant-based meat based yeah
yeah that like beyond me is National
burger they're all it's in every like
fast-food restaurant now so it's it's
taking over and someone's know if you
could do anything in the world for a
career
if Vanderpump rules didn't happen what
would you do make my book into a
television show introducing casted
dreams about casting it before it's like
really trippy yeah who would you get to
play
I don't know I mean obviously if you
weren't playing you yeah I would never
play me it would be so much more fun I
don't know I cause I think it would
because of it evolves over so many
different ages yeah so I would have to
like find like the one that's like in
the late 20s early 30s Kristen and then
start casting based off of whoever that
is oh yeah yeah and you so I feel like
you'd be like an up-and-comer though you
know someone that's not a name mm-hmm
give someone an opportunity yeah okay on
Twitter Marco wants to know which other
reality show would you like to host or
I'm gonna expand this which other
reality show would you want to be on I
would want to be on southern charm
really yeah oh yeah the best time ever
the best time and they don't have to
like be broke waiters and waitresses put
their basic they're essentially us but
like rich southern people and I'm
friends with a lot of them oh yeah yeah
it's like the most fun show have you
guys I mean you guys must create like a
Bravo family like camaraderie with each
other absolutely and even some of like
bachelor nation - I'm not like the
scheana you know out with all of these
guys a roster for like a hot minute I
get it I mean but it's nice to be
friends with people that are on reality
TV because no one understands what we do
oh yeah for us you can just be so
transparent about complaining or being
excited about things or telling secrets
to each other because no one can tell ya
because it's against your contracts
[Laughter]
Kings of spade wants to know are you
living your life to the fullest
that's a hard hell yeah why not I feel
like 2020 is big year for you it's gonna
be big here I'm excited maybe not
January that I heard that there's like a
lunar eclipse in January that's gonna
like really [ __ ] with everyone's
emotions you're very witchy yeah so
today is 12:12 it's a full moon okay and
if you believe it tell me I do certainly
do all of it so tell me everything
that's happening 2019 it the numerology
is 12
it's 12/12/12 today and there's the last
full moon of the decade today huh all
right so what does that mean it's well
that's what I asked it's okay so I want
to be crazy yes I text one of my
girlfriends who's sort of like like a
love and businesslike mentor of mine
like very metaphysical and like
spiritual and I was like Sara what does
this mean what do I need to do and she
has breathe calm the [ __ ] down
enjoy because it's mostly very positive
full moon but she was like I'm January
this lunar eclipse it's gonna happen and
everyone's gonna be emotional a spark
and it's gonna throw you it's gonna be
like you're loving loving like personal
relationships first your work and it's
all this crazy shits gonna happen so
Jerry pair for it they're just be aware
that it's like you know what more
curious and retrograde and you're like
[ __ ] yeah but it's like if you know it's
about to happen you just kind of kind of
roll with it a little bit easy yeah this
is like doomsday prepping yeah okay cool
very cool very excited about January
secure right after January February
we're all gonna be okay so there's that
there we go okay last question from
Brune TBB where's the strangest place
that you have cried other than the
survived through the parking lot or
anywhere sir I'm like where have I not
cried I cried a lot of places I've cried
I cried I'm hiking in the Pacific
Palisades are Will Rogers I cried
because there's like this bridge that I
didn't know about this little tiny like
suspension bridge and I had a
full-fledged meltdown I cried on a kayak
my first time kayaking because I don't
like fish and I had another that was a
full-fledged meltdown I made my friend
turn around and take me back to shore I
feel like your second book should be
called full-fledged
okay one more last question meaning of
life says GG the great 1000 you tell me
I don't figuring it out Oh a lot of
people actually I'm gonna condense a
question
your hangover cure if you have one
definitely Mexican coca-cola
okay is a dream mm-hmm [ __ ] ton of water
okay but I'm not I am like the opposite
of the fast-food person I do cucumbers
in watermelon Wow so you go light light
light well it's just like hydrate
hydrate hydrate okay I mean if you have
to puke let it out and go back to sleep
puke and don't rally puking in rallying
unless I'm on vacation there you go let
your body [ __ ] rest yeah especially
I'm 36 I'm almost 37 I can't puke and
rally it's not cute for me to do the
know it's weird
Mima cut to the trailer of the season
the Vanderpump rules have you fun yeah
Kristen thank you so much for being here
before you go every guest that's on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us to them so you're welcome
to open it I don't know if it's vegan so
but maybe don't I'm okay cool you're not
what is this [ __ ] you mean it's the
mercury in retrograde the moon is
[ __ ] all of us okay it's not a short
fortune our prediction for basic which
potion number six sprite flavored wine
oh that's a good hangover cure yeah but
mostly sprite actually it's just for hit
we pour it into an empty bottle of
Prosecco please try it and give us money
there you go done I should've read
finally and not choking that was me
pitching to you on our version of Shark
Tank right okay so where can people find
you find the book find everything in
2020 at Kristen dou T dou te on all
social media platforms
James ma e dot Co on Instagram James May
dot Co on the web cool
and then the book he's making you crazy
available for a pre-order on Amazon and
we like that hashtag hm YC so let's get
that rocking in room yeah pre-order now
it's out in June and
otherwise get ready for the next season
of Vanderpump rules we go here where you
go thank you Chris and it was super fun
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep good bye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa D
months camera operator Katrina Henning
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]